>> In Washington, Florida governor Ron Desantis
gives an eastern opportunity in Iowa over
the weekend after former president trump canceled
a rally there.
Then we are gonna focus on when Florida governor
could be making his already seemingly official
Ann >> Florida governor Ron
[6:30:13 AM]
>> Florida governor Ron Desantis, putting
on a neighbor, unfolding some burgers in an
old-fashioned retail politics in Iowa, ahead
of his expected run for the white house.
Florida governor crisscrossed the state making
the last-minute stop in Des Moines.
[Applause]
>> That was a 15-minute stop that Santos made
it Jethro's barbecue, after trump was supposed
to hold an outdoor rally just a few blocks
away on Saturday, but his campaign canceled
due to a tornado watch in the area.
Something that Desantis's allies trolled him
about, one of, them tweeting, it was a beautiful
evening in Iowa.
CNN's San toro is covering that right now.
Obviously, Desantis is trying to draw macron
tasked with trump, that was pretty abruptly
scheduled after the former president Kendall's
rally, right, Steve?
>> That is exactly, right Kate.
And the key distinction here is that he has
appeared to go
[6:31:14 AM]
that he has appeared to go after trump in
this, but he is so far divided -- divert attacks
on the president.
He preferred show contrast where he shows
his administration versus trump.
He talks about how he shows there is leaks
in his administration, there was no drama,
and there is no chaos that engulf the trump
administration.
He likes to talk about how he would finish
the border wall, which obviously suggests
that trump didn't finish it, something that
you brought up in the town hall from last
week.
And listen to this warning that he issued
to Iowa voters on Saturday talked with the
stakes in 2024.
>> If we make 2024 election a referendum on
Joe Biden and his failures, and if we provide
a positive alternative for the future of this
country, Republicans will win across the board.
If we do not do that, if we get distracted,
if we focus the election on the past or on
other side issues, then I think the Democrats
are going to beat
[6:32:16 AM]
the Democrats are going to beat us again,
and I think it will be very difficult to recover
from that defeat.
>> You will notice he didn't mention president
trump there but it was very obvious who he
was talking about.
This is something we are seeing from Republicans
across the board.
There is a bit of a tentativeness to going
directly at trump, and that is something that
we are seeing as well from governor santas
while he remains not yet a presidential candidate.
>> It will be notable to see how does Desantis
handle what trump was doing last week.
He was still denying the results of the last
election, and another question here, as we've
seen Desantis in Iowa, we know, of course,
what he's doing there.
The question still is when he is actually
going to officially enter this race now that
Florida legislator is doing this work.
What is your sense when the timing could happen.
>> My sources are telling me there is one
big box left for him to check, and he wants
to go through the state budget.
He likes to go line through line, cut spending
where he can, but once he gets that behind,
[6:33:17 AM]
but once he gets that behind, him then we
are going to see the countdown really start.
My sources suggest late may, first week in
June is a likely timeframe.
But, I have to tell you, just seeing him this
past weekend in Iowa, traveling with him in
sioux center, they were Desantis 2024 signs.
There was a bus there providing super pac,
saying Santa's for